.vsコードのフォルダについて説明したいと思います
ここにはextensions.jsonとsettings.jsonの2つのファイルがあります
このextensions.jsonにはおすすめのvsコードの拡張機能が一覧で書かれています
こういう設定があるので最初ですね右下の方におすすめの拡張機能はこれですみたいなポップアップが出ていたわけです
なのでこれらの拡張機能をそれぞれ入れていきますね
まずview.borrですね
これはview.jsを扱う上で最も重要な拡張機能になりまして
これがですねないとvsコードは.viewファイルを正しく認識してくれないんですね
なのでこんな風に真っ白になってしまいます
でこの拡張機能を入れるとこんな風に正しくvsコードが.viewファイルを認識して色付けしてくれます
なのでまずはこのview.borrをインストールしてください
その上でcreateviewでeslintとpretierを選択している場合はこんな風にeslintとpretierの拡張機能もおすすめされるようになっています
なのでまずこちらのeslintの拡張機能から入れたいと思います
このですね拡張機能がもしインストールされていない場合は
例えばですけれどもjavascriptのファイルとかで存在しないデータを書いた場合
これですね特に何も起こりません
ちょっとファイル保存しますね
こちらのファイルのセーブで保存できますし
macの方はcommand s windowsの方はcontrol sのキーボードショートカットでも保存することができます
今後私はですね何かファイルを変更した後は毎回command sで保存していますので
特に何も言ってない場合は毎回保存しているんだなと思っておいてください
でこの状態で特に何も起こらないんですけれども
npm run lintコマンドでeslintを実行すれば
こんな風にhello is not definedとeslintが静的に解析してエラーを出してくれたりします
がこの機能ですねこちらのeslintの拡張機能をインストールすれば
もうこんな風にnpm run lintコマンドを入力しなくても
赤い波線を出してくれるようになりまして
しかもそれをホバーするとhello is not definedとeslintのエラーのメッセージが出るようになります
なのでlintのエラーをすぐに気づくことができますので
ぜひですねこちらのeslintの拡張機能もインストールするようにしてください
その上でもう一つpretiaの拡張機能ですね
こちらはインストールすることで
pretiaをvsコード上のフォーマッターとして使うことができるようになります
どういうことかというと
例えばですけれどもこんな風にファイルを汚くした上で
vsコードでは右クリックをした上で
このフォーマットドキュメントwithという項目をクリックしたら
特定のフォーマッターでファイルをフォーマットすることができるんですね
そこにpretiaという選択肢が今の拡張機能を入れることで
使用できるようになります
なのでこのpretiaを選択すると
こんな風に綺麗にpretiaのルールに従ってフォーマットされるようになります
追加の説明になります
リンターにoxlintが追加されたことで
おすすめの拡張機能にoxc.oxc-vsコードという
oxlintの拡張機能も追加されました
なのでこちらも同じようにインストールするようにしてください
このままsettings.jsonの説明もしたいと思います
まずこちらの上の2つは
vsコード上でファイルの見た目を整理するために
こんな風にフォルダみたいに開いたり閉じたりさせることができるようにするものです
特に普通にファイルがあると思っていただいて構いません
でその下のeditor.codeactionsonsafe
こちらをですねざっくり
eslintやoxlintの拡張機能に対する設定になります
でこれは何のためにあるのかっていうと
eslintやoxlintって基本的にはコードの品質をチェックするためのもので
ここ変な書き方になっているよみたいなものを
あらかじめ教えてくれます
ただ明らかにちょっと修正したら良くなるものに対しては
そのまま修正してくれたりするんですね
でこれはその修正をファイルの保存時に行ってくれるようにするというものです
なので例えばですけれども
main.jsでlet xイコール10として
let yイコール5としますね
で例えばif分の条件分岐みたいなものを書いたときに
xがyより大きいとき
またはxとyが同じときというコードを書いたとします
でこれってつまりxはy以上という意味ですよね
でJavaScriptでは以上というものは
x大なりイコールyという
よりシンプルで分かりやすい書き方があります
なのでリンターもですね
ちゃんとこの大なりイコールの演算子を使うべきですよと
なっているんですけれども
こういう明らかに簡単に修正できるものに対して
リンターは修正を行ってくれるんですね
なのでちょっとですね一度こちらの
editor.code action zone saveをコメントアウトして
保存した上で
npm run rintとしますね
そうするとこんな風に自動で修正を行ってくれます
でこの修正をですね
こちらのeditor.code action zone saveがあることで
ちょっと戻しますけれども
ファイルの保存時に行ってくれるというものになります
なので一度戻して
コントロールレスでコマンドレスで保存しても
こんな風にちゃんと修正されるということですね
これがこちらの設定になります
非常に便利ですのでぜひこのままにしておいてください
あとこの下の2つは何かっていうと
pretierの設定になります
でこのですねデフォルトフォーマッターの設定の方が
pretierをvsコードにおける
デフォルトのフォーマッターにするという設定になります
なのでこんな風にしておくと
フォーマットをですね
するときに右クリックして
フォーマットドキュメントwithではなくて
こっちの1つのフォーマットドキュメント
こちらをですね押してもこんな風に
デフォルトのフォーマッターが
pretierとしてvsコードが認識していますので
pretierのルールに従って
フォーマットされるようになります
その上でこっちのフォーマットオンセーブの機能
これがですね保存時に
リンターと同じような感じなんですけれども
フォーマットを提供させるというものになります
なのでこの機能がトゥルーになっているおかげで
pretierもですねファイルの保存時に自動で
こんな風に機能するようになっています
なのでeslintの修正だったり
pretierのフォーマットというのが
ファイルの保存時に自動で行われるようにするのが
こちらの設定になります
ちなみにこの機能は
ショートカットキーのコマンドSやコントロールSを使っても
ちゃんと適用されるようになります
あとeslintやpretierやoxlintの設定に関しては
こちらの設定ファイルで変更することができます
基本はですねデフォルトの設定でいいんですけれども
こちらのeslintの設定ファイルの
pluginview.configsのところに書かれている
flatスラッシュエッセンシャルのエッセンシャルの部分
エッセンシャルというのは最低限必要なものみたいな意味なんですけれども
ここをですね
recommenditに変更することができます
こうすると最低限必要なものから
おすすめのものということで
より厳しいルールで
ビジネスのコードをチェックしてくれるようになります
なのでこんな風に設定しておくことをおすすめします
ちなみにここの設定によって
oxlintが対応する
コードをチェックするルールに対しては
eslintは何もしないという風になっています
また実はeslintは
フォーマットの機能も一部持っていたりするんですね
その上でこのスキップフォーマッティングの設定のおかげで
pretierと競合するeslintのフォーマットの設定は
全てスキップされて無視されるようになります
なので全てうまく被らないようにできていますので
ご安心ください
あとですね
こちらのeditor configなんですけれども
editor configってのは
どんなエディターを使っていたとしても
統一したコーディングスタイルにしましょうと
するためにあるんですけれども
こちらの設定もですね
pretierと被ることがあります
ただその場合は
pretierが自動的に
何も設定をしていなければ
こっちのeditor configに関わってある設定で
pretierのデフォルトの設定を
上書きしてくれるようになります
なのでこっちのeditor configの設定が
優先されるわけですね
またこのeditor configの設定を
そもそもこのvsコード自体が
理解して認識するためには
実はデフォルトではですね
これ認識しておらず
専用の拡張機能を入れる必要があります
これもですね
こちらの.vsコードの
extensions.jsonのところに
おすすめとして書かれております
のでこちらをですね
インストールする必要がありますので
こんな風に検索して出てくるものを
インストールします
ちょっとこれインストールする前に
見たいんですけれども
例えば
こちらのeditor configの
インデントサイズ
つまりタブを押した時に
空白がいくつあるか
という意味なんですけれども
これがですね
今このvsコードは
この設定を理解していないので
適用されないんですけれども
その場合ですね
vsコードはデフォルトで
タブを一つ押した時の
空白のサイズは
4つになります
これ1,2,3,4
4つありますよね
これはですね
vsコード自体でもし
この設定を変えたい場合は
vsコードの設定で
タブのサイズのところを
4から2とかに変えると
変更できるんですけれども
ここをですね
いちいち設定しなくても
拡張機能の
editor configを
インストールすれば
もうvsコードは
この
ドットエディターコンフィグの
設定を
見るようになりますので
こちらの設定で
vsコード側の
設定も
上書きされまして
今だとですね
タブを一つ押したら
こんな風に
スペース2つ分になったりします
これが
editor configですね
なので
こちらの
editor configの
拡張機能も
同時に入れておいてください
さあついにですね
Vue.jsを学び
始める準備が
完全に整いました
それでは早速
次のレクチャーから
Vue.jsについて
詳しく学んでいきましょう